restrictions ease across the globe as
the world holds its breath the media
remain is frivolous and ever and so do
our politicians and we examine what it's
like to have a baby in a time of
coronavirus I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by Express at
VPN don't let others track what you do
keep yourself safe and express it VPN
comm / pen well I hope that you had a
wonderful weekend we're gonna get to all
of the news including people actually
having a wonderful weekend in certain
areas of the country and just for one
second first you may have noticed that
things are kind of a volatile
economically speaking you don't know
which way the stock market is going to
go you don't know what the government is
going to do with inflation how that's
going to in fact affect your savings you
you need to take some of your money and
diversify I mean your money needs to be
diversified
that means precious metals over 26
million people have now lost their jobs
because of this coronavirus pandemic
even with the stock market slightly
recovering we just don't know what
things are going to look like in two
weeks or three or three months or a year
think of the position you'd be in now if
you had had a portion of your retirement
tied to precious metals before for
enviros upended the global economy it is
not too late to secure your future call
my friends over at Birch gold right now
I can do a lot for you including if
you're interested converting your
traditional IRA or 401k into a precious
metals IRA no matter what you do you
should have some of your money in
precious metals before May 31st with a
qualifying purchase Birch gold will give
you a free emergency kit the backpack
absolutely loaded with everything you
can't buy right now so safeguard your
savings with Birch gold they'll help
safeguard your family like that in mind
there's no obligation you have nothing
to lose other than to take that first
step
Birch gold group they have thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews and a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau don't wait until
the market drops more I mean you just
don't know what's coming so you should
talk to them over at Birch gold group
text my name Ben - 47 47 47 and
diversify today again text Ben - 47 47
47 when you invest with them you do get
a free emergency context Ben - 47 47 47
for more information okay so the world
is beginning to unlock the lock downs
are starting to end not just in the
United States but everywhere and one of
the things that's always been very weird
about how the media have treated the
situation in the United States is that
they're treating the situation in the
United States as though the United
States exists in a vacuum
it doesn't other places in the world saw
deaths arising about the same time as
the United States and many of them are
starting to relieve lockdown lockdowns
at the same time as the United States
countries that were much harder hit than
the United States
here's the reality of the situation by
the way the United States was really
hard hit in one place New York at every
other place in the United States we had
some places that were sort of moderate
but in terms of broad span United States
if you took New York out of the
calculations meaning its population as
well as the number of deaths from
coronavirus the United States has the
same about number of deaths per hundred
thousand residents from coronavirus as
Germany does and Germany is leading the
pack right now in terms of Western
European countries and how they are
doing with this thing so really is New
York centric New York is a is an oddity
because New York is so crowded because
the the rates of transmission are higher
in New York simply because people are
right on top of each other taking the
subway that doesn't really exist
anywhere else in the United States in
the same way that it does in New York
which is why New York City has seen
12,000 or so deaths and those are just
ones that have been counted the truth is
is probably a little bit higher other
places in the world they've been harder
hit places like Spain places like Italy
these are places that are starting to
relieve their lockdowns right now
according to the AP Spain let children
go outside and place on there for the
first time in six weeks as European
countries methodically worked to ease
their lock downs and reopen their
economies while governors in the United
States moved to different speeds some
more aggressive others more cautious
around the world China's state-run media
said that hospitals in Wuhan the
original epicenter of the disaster no
longer have any Cove in 19 patients
after a crisis in which the city
recorded nearly 4,000 deaths now do we
believe China on that probably not
they've actually locked down movie
theaters again in Beijing so that
suggests that this thing is not in fact
dead so anything that comes out of
Beijing cannot be trusted but Prime
Minister Boris Johnson in Britain is
planning to be back at his desk Monday
at 10 Downing Street after he had
coronavirus governors in states like New
York and Michigan are keeping stay at
home restrictions in place until at
least in May but even those governors
are starting to figure out exactly how
they transition back to regular life
especially for people who are not in
major urban areas major cities with
heavy population densities their
counterparts in places like Georgia
Oklahoma Alaska are starting to allow
certain businesses to reopen churches in
Montana began holding in-person services
again on Sunday and that does make some
sense because again a lot of these
states have not been heavily damaged a
lot of these states never went into
lockdown in the first place and we're
still not heavily damaged and it is
important to recognize that it was
failures in specifically high population
places that led to certain things
getting out of control
New York City did not lock down until
very late bill de blasio did not lock
down New York City until nearly the end
of March like a full week after the
entire state of California locked down
Andrew Cuomo
still had a rule in place for weeks that
if you were infected with coronavirus
and you were elderly they had to accept
you back at your nursing home which is
like the worst idea ever they did the
same thing in California by the way in
Italy one of the big reasons that things
went a raged out of control in Italy is
specifically because it was high
population density and also because of
the demographics and healthcare
deficiencies according to the Associated
Press biologists and epidemiologists say
what went wrong in Lombardi will be
studied for years given how the outbreak
overwhelmed the medical system long
considered to be one of Europe's best
well in the neighboring Veneto region
the impact was significantly more
controlled Lombardi's frontline doctors
and nurses are being hailed as heroes
for risking their lives to treat the
sick under extraordinary levels of
stress exhaustion isolation and fear
what exactly happened while Italy was
the first European country talked to all
air traffic with China on January 31st
even put scanners and airports to check
arrivals for fever by January 31st it
was already too late epidemiologists now
say the virus had been circulating
widely in Lombardi since early January
if not before and that is at least
partly the fault of China which was
still lying to the World Health
Organization and saying there was no
human to human transmission doctors
treating pneumonia in January and
February didn't know it was the corona
virus because the symptoms were so
similar and the virus was still believed
to be largely confined to China even
after Italy registered a February 21st
case which was its first death doctors
didn't understand the unusual wake of it
19 could present itself with patients
experiencing a rapid decline in their
ability to breathe one of the weird
things about kovin 19 is that people
will arrive in the hospital and seem to
be breathing fine but their oxygen
saturation levels are like 50% so it's
very odd because normally when you have
that sort of oxygen saturation you're
struggling and gasping for breath that's
actually not happening people are
desaturating really really quickly
because Lombardi si si use we're already
filling up within days of Italy's first
cases many primary care physicians tried
to treat and monitor patients at home
some putting them on supplemental oxygen
commonly used for home cases in Italy
that strategy proved deadly because
people waited too long to call
ambulances Italy was forced to use home
care in part because of its low ICU
capacity after years of budget cuts
Italy entered the crisis with 8.6 ICU
beds per 100,000 people the OECD average
Oh II see D is the is the basically
industrialized West they have an average
of fifteen point nine ICU beds per
100,000 people Germany has 33 point nine
ICU beds per hundred thousand people so
Italy was not
like the united states which is one of
the reasons why even in new york the
healthcare system was not in fact
overwhelmed and so the united states is
starting to reopen things we're starting
to see different states treating this
thing differently which by the way is
the way that this should work we should
see different states treating this thing
differently pretending that all states
are equivalent in their approach to this
is full-scale idiocy New York City is
not like Tennessee for example even New
York is starting to consider how they
can reopen at this point according to
the New York Times with promising
indications that the coronavirus
contagion has passed its peak Governor
Andrew Cuomo of New York laid out a
broad outline on Sunday for a gradual
restart of the state that would allow
some low-risk businesses upstate to open
as soon as mid-may honestly he should be
opening those up right now like there's
really no reason what there's not a lot
of travel inside the state of New York
right now there's no reason why upstate
New York like what Rochester should be
treated exactly like New York City they
never had the outbreak levels of New
York City
the governor's announcement coming as
the state recorded its lowest death
daily toll in nearly a month was filled
with caveat but nonetheless offered a
clearest outline yet for recovery in New
York the National Center of the outbreak
with nearly 17,000 people dead that
humans devastation has largely been
confined thus far to New York City and
its sprawling suburbs under Cuomo's plan
upstate regions would move forward with
reopening long before downstate with an
emphasis on manufacturing and
construction industries in which
telecommuting and working from home are
impossible Cuomo said such changes could
occur shortly after May 15th that's when
the statewide stay-at-home order is
scheduled to lapse he says that many of
the restrictions on business and
residents activity could be continued
for weeks if not months he said no
restrictions will be loosened in New
York City in the near future which does
raise the question as to how exactly he
plans to reopen New York I mean this is
one of the big problems in New York City
because everybody is so closely packed
together and because it is very
difficult I cannot even imagine how you
actually perform contact tracing in
someplace like New York City I really
don't know the answer to that this thing
spreads incredibly quickly if the
subways are still open how do you
possibly contact trace a subway car hell
you're stuck in a subway car for 15
minutes you infect everybody in the car
those people get out and get on other
Subway's there's a reason why New York
City was according to the antibody test
at least 21 percent infected and that
that is a very very high infection rate
considering they went in a full-scale
lockdown in late March so I don't know
what he thinks is going to be the
necessary level of contact tracing in
order for them to reopen in New York
City or whether New York City is
basically just going Taft up or operate
at low level until the vaccine is
developed if they don't want another
outbreak or whether they're just gonna
have to live with the new normal and
recognize that if you are young and you
are healthy then you're gonna have to go
back to work you're gonna wear a mask
you're in a socially distance and if you
are older or vulnerable then you're
gonna have to shelter in place as you
can but there are no good solutions for
New York City and the the it is unclear
whether the worst solution is a total
lockdown or basically social distancing
it seems to me that these lock downs are
not really achieving what they anything
beyond what they're originally set to
achieve which is preventing the
overwhelm of the health care system and
korma by the way has already
acknowledged that the system was not
overwhelmed in New York City they did
not lack ventilators they just sent away
the USS comfort and said that they were
not actually over one the Javits Center
was not full of people suffering from
Koba 19 that's not what happened the
Samaritan's Purse Park Hospital in
Central Park they were not overwhelmed
so you're starting to see other cities
beside New York reopened in Georgia a
close-contact retail businesses like
barbers and tattoo parlors were allowed
to open on Friday areas were large
numbers of people congregate late movie
theatres were expected to accept
customers on Monday the mayors of large
cities like Atlanta and Augusta have
resisted Governor Brian come's call for
reopening mr. Cuomo says that he was
closely monitoring hospitalization
infection and recovery rates in the city
and regionally with an eye toward the
federal guidelines released by the White
House ten days ago governor Phil Murphy
of New Jersey also says he's going to
begin to lay out a vision for reopening
his state which has also lost thousands
of lives due to coronavirus now one of
the things that you're attaining is when
you hear people like Murphy say things
like this the road back will be driven
by data science and common sense ok yes
all of these solutions are gonna be
driven by data science and common sense
the suggestion that if people disagree
with you they are anti science is just
absurd the science does not dictate what
the political priorities are or what the
balance is going to be and to be
accurate you should acknowledge that
there's gonna be a lot of vagary there's
gonna be a lot of trial and error and
there's gonna be a lot of of just having
to catch-as-catch-can
because that is the reality of the
situation Ed Cuomo is pleading with
local officials to consider how to
provide for summer activities for
residents including children
Mayor Bill DeBlasio has already said the
city's public swimming pools will not
open in the summer the playgrounds are
still shut for the time being
Cuomo said you can't tell people in
dense urban environment all through the
summer months we don't have anything for
you to do there's a sanity equation here
weird because I remember Andrew Cuomo
saying last week there is no contrast
between human lives and lost jobs and
lost livelihoods so which is it I mean I
said last week that Cuomo was lying
about that and he was the fact is that
you're going to have to balance all of
these competing priorities and come up
with the best available solution now
he's saying we can't keep the
playgrounds in the pools closed all
summer long because people are gonna go
insane what do you think happens when
people lose their jobs on mass Andrew
Cuomo also mayor de Blasio says we're
gonna come back stronger and fairer
which is always the key word for
Democrats stronger and fairer means
they're gonna try to radically
restructure the economy when you get to
that in a little bit but palomo says the
data will be evaluated in two-week
increments and the companies wanting to
restart work would be individually
evaluated to determine how essential a
service does that businesses provide and
how risky is that business know how
essential the service is is really not
the business of the government and that
sort of language needs to die okay it's
not the job of andrew cuomo to determine
how essential services you know how
essential the services exactly how many
people are willing to patronize the
service under conditions like these
that's how essential the services people
get to decide that not andrew Cuomo that
is full on government control language
and it needs to stop when we said
essential workers originally what we
really meant were people who are just
keeping you alive right like health care
workers or food supply workers but if we
are talking about how reporters are
essential workers but people who are
working in manufacturing are not that's
just a bunch of crap coming from the
government it's just it's it's nonsense
it's nonsense
okay in just a second we're gonna get to
more of this we're going to talk about
one of the problems here which is the
lack of standards and the failure of
local authorities to set up reasonable
standards we can get to that in just one
second first let's talk about your the
simple fact you are now doing more
online shopping than ever before we know
by the way that the retail industry in
the United States is going to decline
right now and that online shopping is
going to become ever more prevalent well
here's a great way for you to save money
really easily and for free over online
and that is at honey calm we all shop
online a lot but honey is the free
online shopping tool that saves you
money online honey will automatically
find the best promo codes and then apply
them to your cart which makes online
shopping finally feel as easy as it is
supposed to be imagine you're shopping
on one of your favorite sites Target
Best Buy Sephora Macy's Amazon when you
checkout there's a little
box that drops down all you have to do
is click apply coupons and then you wait
a few seconds for it to scan for every
single promo code on the internet and
then you can just watch the prices drop
I've saved hundreds of dollars using
honey myself honey has found it so for
18 million members over 2 billion
dollars in savings it's a lot of money
that you can say by using honey and
again
you're passing up free money if you
don't use honey it is free to use it
installs in just a few seconds plus it's
backed by PayPal so you know it's good
get honey for free at join honey calm
slash pen that is join honey dot-com
slash pen again join honey calm slash
pen right that's a great way to save
money
join honey dot-com / Ben okay so when we
look at how states are reopening it is
relevant to see that people are being
responsible so here is the key question
do you trust Americans to be responsible
or do you not trust Americans to be
responsible this in the end is going to
be the key question because without
things radically changing things are
just not gonna radically change and I
know that's a truism but it is true okay
truisms are true because our truisms
because they are true if nothing
radically changes vaccine is not
developed if no great therapeutics are
come up with the math is gonna be the
same no matter what you do and so the
question now becomes can you trust
people to take responsible action in
their daily lives to prevent other
people from getting the disease can you
lock down the most vulnerable areas and
if your if you are calling for heavy
levels of testing and contact tracing
you're gonna have to explain how that
really works in places like New York
City what level of testing how many
tests per day are necessary in New York
City how many contact tracers are
necessary in New York City how are you
going to perform that when the vast
majority of people with this thing are
asymptomatic we now know that antibodies
are formative 21 percent of the
population in New York City but only
one-tenth of that have actually been
tested they've had about 200,000 cases
in New York City 20 percent of the
population in New York City is somewhere
around 1.7 million people I said so to
pretend that you're gonna contact race
millions and millions of people pretty
much every day is gonna be very very
difficult and this is especially true
when we're not ramping up testing like
this when people say that we're gonna
ramp up testing to 20 million a day
they're insane fewer than 2% of the
United States has actually been tested
at this point five million people have
been tested at this point the problem
with the test is if you test negative
that doesn't mean you're gonna test
negative next week for Kovan 19 so you
could test all
300 million people today and that does
not guarantee that you've gotten rid of
coronavirus coronavirus is not going to
be got rid of so what this relies on is
people being responsible and here's the
thing I think the American people are
responsible I think they're more
responsible than our media and our
politicians I'll tell you that if I have
to if I have to determine whom to trust
members of our political class members
of the chattering class or lucky people
like me who can sit in places like their
house and broadcast to you and still
have their jobs or the normal Americans
who can be trusted to go out and take
responsible measures
I trust normal Americans I do and if you
don't trust normal Americans I wonder
what you're doing living in a republic I
don't think people want to kill other
people I really know and I'll give you
some examples so over the weekend there
was a heatwave in California it was
really amazing weather outside it was
like 90 degrees in California 85 90
degrees in California at least Southern
California and it was just it was
fantastic and if you are a Californian
this is like your time right you go out
to the beach you really party up so LA
County shut down all of its parks in all
of his beaches which is full-scale
idiocy what they really should be doing
is they should have police officers at
parks and on beaches telling people that
they need to least socially distance if
that's how you want to implement and
implements it that way but my family not
like literally every family I know
yesterday went to a park and by the way
if you couldn't go to a park in LA we
went outside of La or you went to
Burbank or you went to Pasadena or you
went to Oxnard 31 to Newport Beach so
yesterday my family me my wife my three
kids we all went to a park in in Burbank
/ Pasadena and people were being
responsible there were lots of people
there and people were 30 40 feet away
from each other and nobody got close to
each other everybody was staying away
from the common areas all of the benches
were taped off all the tables were taped
off all the playgrounds were taped up it
was a nice fun open area playing frisbee
with the kids I wasn't the only one I
was flying a kite with the kids right
there people can do this responsibly
they can most people were wearing masks
even though they really didn't need to
hear 30 feet away from somebody else
okay well there's a big story over the
weekend 40,000 people showed up in
Newport Beach why because everybody came
from LA County because LA County is
stupid and they shut down all of their
parks and beaches all that ended up
doing was shuffling all the people who
wanted to go to the beach to one beach
right everybody wants a Newport Beach or
Huntington Beach so 40,000 people show
up and the way the media cover this is
just
Terraria there's gonna be widespread
disease in Newport Beach when you
actually watch the video that that was
put together by local news you have to
ask yourself how many of these people
actually are like less than six feet
away from each other and are not in the
immediate social distancing group right
like me and my family I don't have to
distance for my wife and my kids the
question is how far are we away from the
next group of people who are isolating
at home so people are going nuts over
this the pictures from above show people
15 20 feet apart pretty far apart from
one another here's a little bit of the
media coverage of it though which is
disaster area people dying in this
reason I don't think so I think the
American most Americans are being
responsible here Battalion Chief Brian
O'Rourke estimates 40,000 people on
Newport Beach Friday twice as many as
Thursday and he says many are from LA
and San Diego can you go back for a
second and just look at that above shot
okay there's a helicopter shot of
Newport Beach look how far these people
are away from each other right there's
from a helicopter so those people are
far away from each other they look as
though it's a lot of people that is a
lot of people standing very very far
away from one another
hey I'm not spotting a ton of people who
are sitting two feet away from another
from one another these people are are at
least six feet away from one another in
open air sunlight does kill this thing
by the way according to the Washington
Post some half the virus could be killed
in as little as two minutes if it's on a
surface surface exposed to sunlight and
high humidity at room temperature
according to the Washington Post
health 202 blog which by the way is
really good it's a good source for
information we're not talking about
bringing sunlight inside the body or
something we're just talking about the
fact that people who are outside in open
air where it is hot are less likely to
obtain this disease okay so people are
socially distancing you can continue to
play the video and he says many are from
LA in San Diego we're seeing a huge
increase which with crowds that we would
normally see out here in the middle of
the summer so they've beefed up
lifeguard patrol and asked people to
please social distance we really want
people to be safe so sometimes we're
torn when we get these huge crowds if
you come and you act like this like
there's nothing wrong and everyone's
here throwing a football and having a
beer with their buddy you know that's
that's how you ruin it for the rest of
us who are safe social distancing yeah
a question if you're having a beer with
your buddy and you guys are like living
in the same apartment I wonder how's
that not social distancing seriously
like a you live in the apartment with
them I mean my producer Colton lives in
an apartment with a roommate right where
he already did until shortly 9 he lives
with roommates ok so most people who are
at young live with roommates because
they can't afford national apartment on
their own if you go out with your buddy
you're throwing a football around that
is still social distancing most people
are being whisper and I'm speaking from
personal experience at the park
yesterday families staying away from one
another hey I'll give you another
example there's a video going around and
it's fantastic of this woman in Georgia
who's reopening her hair salon and the
way she describes how she's reopening
her hair salon this is great Americans
doing great American stuff there's a
woman explaining exactly how she went
about reopening her business burn mask
we're gonna have gloves on we need you
to wear masks as well you'll come up to
this window big sign check in here
there's instructions to sanitize this
sit in your car and wait on your stylist
to come get you once your stylist comes
and gets even you will be able to enter
into the salon upon checking out we do
have you also have your temperature
checked so be prepared for that okay so
this is a person who is being
responsible and then people like this
are being ripped or she just wants to go
get ahead no she wants to reopen her
business and people are being
responsible now this doesn't mean that
the authorities aren't going overboard
so yesterday in Oxnard I have a close
family friend and he went with his
family to Oxnard okay because Oxnard is
not in LA County it's a Oxnard County
Ventura County and he and people were
staying away from each other far away
from each other and in a second I'm
going to show you what happened when the
police decided to show up in her and
basically harass a 93 couple because
everything is stupid we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about this being your chance to become
your favorite your parents favorite
child okay here's the reality you can't
visit mom and dad in many cases right
now what you can do is make sure that
they know that they are cared about and
that means that mom gets flowers for
Mother's Day this Mother's Day celebrate
her with 1-800 flowers calm right now
when you order early at one in her and
flowers and get 30s
tulips for 20% off the original price
which is a great way to make every mom
feel loved especially when it matters
most Mother's Day is coming up and since
Mother's Day is coming up by the way and
you can't see mom what better way to
celebrate than getting her a beautiful
bouquet of flowers to make sure that she
remembers that you're not just taking
advantage of the social distancing not
to visit with a bright mix of orange
yellow and pink blooms these tulips are
guaranteed to show all the moms in your
life just how much they're loved by the
way these flowers are spectacular like
every time I go out of town
I send my white flowers from 1-800
flowers she loves it every single time
1-800 flowers is committed to the safety
of their team members and your family so
all deliveries are contactless picking
an early delivery date ensures your
bouquet will arrive in time to make mom
stay special by the way these flowers
also last like a really long time a lot
longer than this stuff you get over the
grocery 30 assorted tulips for $39.99
it's an amazing offer availability is
limit limited
hurry and order before Friday with
limited delivery windows you need to
lock in that order early don't put it
off order today from the official
florist of Mother's Day 1-800 flowers
calm order those 30 tulips for $39.99 go
to 1-800 flowers calm / Shapiro that's
1-800 flowers calm / appear oh the offer
does and Friday 1-800 flowers calm /
Schapiro go there and use code apparel
1-800 flowers calm / appear oh go check
them out right now
okay so the American people are being
responsible that's not stopping the
authorities from being forced to
implement some of the dumbest words I've
ever seen so over in Oxnard this is a
tape from yesterday my friend was he
took a video of it cuz he couldn't
believe it there are cops on horses
going up to a 93 year old couple Cory
there's nobody by the way within like 40
feet of this 93 year old couple right
there
you think the 93 year old couple once
again covered their dead if they get not
have a guy covered right there they're
socially distancing they brought their
own folding chairs and the cops went
over them and told them they were not
allowed to sit on the folding chairs
they're 93
they're not allowed to sit on the
folding chairs why so they're allowed to
sit on the ground but they're not
allowed to sit on the folding chairs
because folding chairs according to the
Oxnard cops are permanent whereas if you
sit on the sand that is not permanent
which is just insane I'm sorry that's
totally crazy since when has bringing
your own folding chair and sitting on
the beach been a sign of permanence
these people were 93 years old
unbelievable it's so stupid so do you
trust the American people or do not
trust the American people and it is
stunning honestly
these sort of soft bigotry of low
expectations applied to the American
people here there's an article in New
York Times about how some black leaders
in Georgia are upset with the state
allowing stores to reopen according to
the New York Times several African
American leaders in Georgia including
the mayors of Atlanta Savannah and
Augusta criticized the decision by
Governor Brian Kemp to allow gyms and
barber shops tattoo parlors and spas in
the state to reopen last Friday houses
of worship to resume in-person services
and restaurants and theaters to reopen
on Monday that stance seems to put them
in agreement with President Trump who
said the move was quote-unquote too soon
but stacey abrams distanced herself from
the president she said I give the
president no credit he actually caused
this challenge by tweeting four weeks
that we should liberate our economies
first of all who cares what stacey
abrams has to say i mean at this point
she's basically John Cusack calling up a
boom box outside Joe Biden's house
begging to be picked for vice president
but critics of the early reopening
include influential clergy members like
Jamal Bryant pastor of New Birth
Missionary Baptist in Atlanta area mega
church and the Reverend dr. Raphael
Warnock who's running for the US Senate
in a special election against senator
Kelly Lafleur
a Republican appointed to a seat by
Governor Kemp mr. Bryant in a Facebook
live video said the reopening was
derelict of responsibilities and absent
moral integrity and specifically aimed
at places the African Americans like
together like salons and barbershops
right after many people had received
their stimulus checks so now I'm
confused so if you say that you want to
reopen barber shops and salons somehow
this is racist because according to this
particular pastor Jamal Bryant who's
running for the Senate black folks like
to hang out at salons and barbershops so
if you reopen them then apparently what
what is he saying is he saying the black
people are not capable of being
responsible at barber shops and salons
is that it's arguing cuz that seems kind
of racist to me it seems to me that
black people like all other Americans
are perfectly capable of being
responsible going to barber shops and
salons so the idea here is going to be
that if people are irresponsible and
that if that irresponsibility causes a
spike in cases that is located in a
particular community that's the fault of
the state level government as opposed to
individuals making bad decisions if you
don't want to be infected don't go out
and if you don't want to be infected
social assistance and that would be a
that would be on you being responsible I
understand that we've now created a
cradle-to-grave society in which
nobody's expected to take responsibility
but personal responsibility at this
point would be a very very useful
thing it seems by the way when we speak
about these lock downs they're serious
questions is whether these lock downs
have even worked these are real
questions according to TJ Rodgers
writing for The Wall Street Journal
today the quick shutdowns may not
actually be all that effective according
to the this columnist named TJ Rodgers
for The Wall Street Journal he says to
do quick shutdowns work to fight the
spread of Kove in 1900 male Chow you
know and Weiss and I wanted to find out
we set out to quantify how many deaths
were caused by delayed shutdown orders
on a state-by-state basis to normalize
for an unambiguous comparison of deaths
between states at the midpoints of an
epidemic we count the deaths per million
population for a fixed 21 day period
measured from when the death rate first
hit one per million EG three deaths in
Iowa or 19 in New York State a states
days to shut down was the time after
state crossed the 1 per million
threshold until it ordered businesses
shut down we ran a simple one variable
correlation of deaths per million in
days to shut down which range from minus
10 days some states shut down before any
sign of kovin 19 to 35 days for South
Dakota one of seven states with limited
or no shutdown the correlation
coefficient was five point five percent
so low that engineers I used to employ
would have summarized it as no
correlation and moved on to find the
real cause of the problem no conclusions
can be drawn about the states that
sheltered quickly because their death
rates ran the full gamut from 20 per
million in Oregon to 360 per million in
New York this wide variation means that
other variables like population density
or subway use were much more important
than lock downs our correlation
coefficient for per capita death rates
versus population density was 44% which
suggests New York City might have
benefited from its shut down but blindly
copying New York's policies in places
with a low code 19 death rate such as
native was such as Wisconsin doesn't
make any sense
meanwhile Sweden which has been beaten
up by the left-wing press in the United
States continues to approach herd
immunity since people over 65 account
for about 80 percent of copán 19 deaths
Sweden asked only seniors to shelter in
place rather than shutting down the rest
of the country since Sweden had no
pediatric deaths it didn't shut down
elementary and middle schools Sweden's
containment measures are less onerous
than Americas so it can keep them in
place longer to prevent Cova 19 from
recurring also they probably won't get a
second wave so how did the Swedes do
they suffered 80 deaths per million 21
days after crossing the 1 per million
threshold level with 10 million people
Sweden's death rate is lower than that
of the 7 hardest-hit US states
Massachusetts Rhode Island Louise
Connecticut Michigan New Jersey and New
York all of which except Louisiana shut
down in three days or less Sweden is in
the middle of the pack in Europe
comparable to France better than Italy
Spain in the UK and worse than Finland
Denmark and Norway and also Sweden is
not vulnerable to a second wave because
again there's not gonna be a wave
everybody has been there all the time
right I mean it Sweden is now a lake it
is not an ocean there's not a wave and
then a break and then another wave
instead they basically said okay we're
going to let the water level rise to
what the water level is and then that's
just gonna be the water level the
Swedish ambassador by the way says that
they will reach herd immunity in May
Taran Rika Olaf's daughter told NPR
about 30 percent of people in Stockholm
have reached a level of immunity we
could reach hurt immunity in the capital
as early as next month so a lot of
people seem like they are rooting for
Sweden to fail it seems like we should
really be rooting for Sweden to succeed
because in Sweden succeeds that is going
to mean a life that is much closer to
normal than anything that we are talking
about right now also when we are
deciding public policy it is very
important to determine exactly which
people are dying specifically because
that means we trance populations and
have to say I mean I've been saying this
for literally a month now you have to
transpose and determine who is most
vulnerable and then how do we protect
the people who are most vulnerable
they're treating every individual person
as though they are equally vulnerable is
idiotic people who are older are
significantly more vulnerable to this
and also if you lose a job and lose your
business at 30 and you're balancing that
against an increased risk of somebody
who's 80 that is a balance that has to
be taken into account because the person
who's 30 is gonna live another 50 years
the person who is 80 not to be too blunt
about it is gonna live another one I
mean so that does make a bit of a
difference when you're talking about the
number of days live though all these
calculations sound cold-hearted and
cruel they're called policy making can
the fact is that while all life is
precious quality of life is also quite
precious and we are going to have to
make these decisions otherwise Andrew
Cuomo would just declare an endless
shutdown forever
so would every other Democrat for every
Democrat who says that all it's about is
saving live somebody needs to ask them a
simple question which is okay so why
don't we just shut down forever because
Kovan 19 isn't going away presumably you
want to reopen at some point and there
will be additional risks of the American
public doing statistical analysis of
those of those risks is called being a
responsible policymaker especially in
light of the fact that there are
countervailing concerns about
lockdowns of this sort one of those
countervailing concerns the New York
Times reports on vaccine rates are
actually dropping dangerously for small
children why because parents aren't
going into the pediatrician so that
means that you're gonna see other
childhood diseases spike this year
because parents did not go and get the
measles mumps rubella shot for their
kids according to the New York Times as
parents around the country cancel
well-child checkups to avoid coronavirus
exposure
public health experts fear they are
inadvertently sowing the seeds of
another health crisis immunizations are
dropping at a dangerous rate putting
millions of children at risk for measles
whooping cough and other
life-threatening illnesses that is bad
news we've also seen people who are
under treated for cancer people who
aren't under treated for heart disease
and as we will see the economic impacts
of this thing are extraordinary we'll
get to that in just one second then
we'll get to the deep on seriousness of
our media and politicians because
everything we've discussed up to this
point it's pretty serious policymaking
it's all policy making discussions how
much can we trust the American people
what are the measures that we should
take will social distancing and contact
tracing work how to even contact trace
and big sit like these are the real
questions that need to be asked instead
why don't we have like I don't know a
week long conversation about whether to
inject yourself with with Clorox how
about that let's just do that for like a
week because our media are fundamentally
unserious and does that mean that
President Trump is right to get up there
and speculate foolishly about dumb
things in front of people no it doesn't
mean that we all need to worry deeply
that the American people are going to go
out on mass and start chugging Drano I'm
pretty sure not even get to more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about a simple fact that has literally
never been a better time to not go to
the post office I don't care how much
you like the post office now is a
horrible time to be at the post office
standing in line dealing with surfaces a
lot of other people are dealing with
instead why not do all your mailing from
home and save money in the process this
is where stamps.com comes in anything
you can do at the post office you can do
at stamps calm you can print postage on
demand and skip the lines and crowds at
the post office plus you can actually
save some money with discounts you can't
even get at the post office here at the
daily why are we been using stamps calm
since 2017 we do not waste our time and
we do not waste our money which is why
we are still in business
stamps calm brings all the services of
the US Postal Service directly to your
computer and the safety and comfort of
your own home office anywhere else you
are hunkering down right now whether
you're a small business sending invoices
or an online seller shipping out
products or you're just working from
home you need to mail stuff stamps.com
can handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it once
your mail is ready just leave it for
your mail carrier schedule a free
package pick up or drop it in the
mailbox no human contact is required it
is indeed that simple and like I said
with stamps calm yet great discounts to
five cents off every first-class stamp
up to 40% off usps shipping rights and
now stamp stockholm is also offering UPS
services with discounts up to 62% plus
you don't have to pay UPS residential
surcharges this is a no-brainer right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and digital scale no long
term commitment just go to stamps com
click on the Mike at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro that is
stamps com enter code Shapiro for that
four-week trial plus free postage and
they did general scale no long-term
commitment solid solid deal okay we're
gonna get to more on all of this in a
second including the economic meltdown
that is about to occur and the apparent
desire for a new New Deal even though
the old New Deal probably lengthened the
Great Depression by almost a decade
there are people who are like yeah more
government is a great idea let's inflate
the currency so everybody savings are
worth nothing fantastic fantastic idea
guys let's blow up government programs
that are completely counterproductive
and useless perfect idea we had until
five minutes ago an unemployment rate
that was three point five percent and
the shtetl and a steady growing economy
that had been booming for years and now
you're like let's give all that up and
let's just go full social brilliant
brilliant stuff we'll get to that in a
second first being locked inside right
now requires double the excitement
double the joy double the leftist years
is too leftist years tumblr to hold all
of those cheer rise now when you become
a daily wire insider plus our all-access
member you get a second leftist cheers
tumblr I am not fitting I am not kidding
with Bernie Sanders now out of the race
for president one tumbler just was not
enough to hold all of those leftist
years you need another tumbler to
contain the rage and the anger daily
wire members get many amazing benefits
including of course these magical
magical beverage vessels but you also
get an ad-free website experience
access to all of our live broadcasts
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show access to the mailbag
and now exclusive election insight
op-eds from hua daily where members also
get to ask us questions during backstage
you also get to participate in all
access live that's our brand-new
interactive programming featuring one of
us daily wire host is we hang out with
you each night at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00
p.m. Pacific I believe I'm doing at
least one maybe two this week this is
content for our all-access members
that's been temporarily opened up to all
our members right now because of
having a tough time if you haven't
already download that daily wire app you
can get all of our fantastic content on
the go so again become an Insider plus
or all-access member and double your
tears with two leftist tiers tumblers go
to daily wire calm slash subscribe to
become a member and get 10% off with
coupon code Shapiro's so I mean that's a
pretty solid deal 10% off to leftist
here's tumblers daily we're calm /
subscribe coupon code Schapiro and get
the rarest of beverage vessels x -
you're listening to the largest fastest
core and conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so one of the big questions here is how
fast the economy is going to bounce back
what will not cause the economy to
bounce back as stimulus checks because
right now the only question is how
deeply the demand curve has changed
thanks to coronavirus because let's say
for example that this thing went away
like right now let's say the corn fire
is no longer existed
you wouldn't even you wouldn't need any
government intervention everybody would
go back to work
we don't go out we'd shop we'd go to
movies we do all this stuff we were
doing before and the economy would go
right back to where it was before right
that's a v-shaped recovery but because
demand has now changed the government
intervening can actually really screw up
the new demand curves the government
intervening will prop up industries that
don't actually survive right prop up
retail that's going to fail prop up
people who aren't gonna be able to
afford their mortgages which actually
damages people who can pay their
mortgages and also prevents a quick
recovery prevents labor from moving from
industries that are dying into
industries that are growing now
government intervening in the markets
creates friction and that friction
doesn't allow the fluidity that is
necessary in order to grow the areas of
the economy where people are actually
going to have a long lasting jobs if you
owned a restaurant and let's say that
that restaurant actually is destined to
go under because people have changed
their eating habits right you own a
small bodega and the small bodega only
had ten seats in it in the first place
and now you're talking about social
distancing which means you have one seat
in the small bodega and that means you
can't survive the government propping up
your bodega well it's good for you it's
very bad for the economy long-run
because all the government is doing at
that point is pouring money into a pit
that is never going to be filled what
the government needs to be doing at this
point is merely propping up the
businesses that are likely to survive
and paying the unemployment for people
who lost their jobs until businesses can
grow again and people can move from one
into the other right that's what needs
to happen right now now the Trump
administration is expressing a lot of
optimism Steve minuchin the Treasury
secretary he says the economy is really
gonna bounce back in July and August and
maybe that's the case I will say there
was a feel over the weekend as people
went out to parks and were socially
distancing that people are ready to get
out of their houses alright people do
not want to be stuck in their houses any
longer they're willing to undergo the
travails of going outside with the masks
and socially distancing if it means they
get to participate in life again so I
think there will be a recovery in July
in August I just don't know that
recovery with this many lost jobs is
going to be sufficient in order to grow
the economy anywhere near what we had
before
here's Steve minuchin I think as we
begin to reopen the economy in May and
June you're gonna see the economy really
bounce back in July August September and
we are putting in an unprecedented
amount to fiscal relief into the economy
you're seeing trillions of dollars
that's making its way into the economy
and I think this is going to have a
significant impact okay this you know it
may have an impact in terms of just
tithing people over but the reality is
that according to the CBO the
unemployment rate will be above 10
percent next year okay we're at 3.5% two
months ago the White House economic
advisor Kevin Hassett told reporters on
Sunday that the jobless rate is likely
to hit 16 percent or more in April he
says I think the next month a couple of
months are gonna look terrible
you're gonna see numbers as bad as
anything we've ever seen before which is
exactly right and that's despite the
next wave of IRS quote-unquote stimulus
payments that we really need to come up
with the betters from the stimulus
payments it is not a stimulus a stimulus
is designed to get you to spend money
this is not what this is this is a
fill-in the government drove a hole
through your through your house right
this is a reparation essentially this is
the government did damage to you and now
the government is forced to repay the
damage that they did to you Social
Security beneficiaries and people who
gave the IRS deposit information are on
tap they are going to get their checks
this is not going to help the economy
recover because again people need to
know what they are going to spend on
before we can determine where all the
jobs are going to go now this is driving
people on the Left to suggest that the
time for big government is back it's
time for big bad government
Ayana presley's a good example of this
the Ringo Starr of the squad
Diana Presley represented from
Massachusetts basically she called
yesterday for free everything she wants
to completely restructure the American
economy this is what scares the hell out
of me one of the reasons that we need
people to go back to work one of the
reasons that if you are healthy and can
go back to work then we need to transfer
back into the economy is because there
are too many people on the Left who are
rooting for the government to fill the
gap here rooting for the government to
completely remake all of American
society off the back of a pandemic since
they had a really tough time arguing two
months ago that the economy was failing
and therefore we needed to remake all of
human life now that the economy has been
basically Neutron bombed by the
government they're saying the government
needs to come in and and rebuild a
Marshall Plan for America here is Ayana
Presley basic
suggesting the complete regulation and
government overthrow of private areas of
American life the things that I'll be
fighting for student debt cancellation
we need rent and mortgage cancellation
in Maya and not just residential but
commercial as well more money for
community health centers because they
serve our most vulnerable or are
undocumented in our immigrant family
friends and neighbors
what else do wreak cash assistance more
support for our food banks because food
insecurity has been the number one issue
that I've heard yeah so some of those
ideas were arguing also the rest of it
relieving student loan debt know you can
delay payments while people don't have
jobs you can renegotiate payments just
getting rid of them getting rid of
mortgages like what is she even talking
about you can hear the eagerness with
which Democrats are talking about their
proposed restructuring rahm emanuel who
coined the phrase never let a good
crisis go to waste rallies popularized
it he said the era of ronald reagan that
said basically the government is the
enemy is over and then steve Bannon
who's just a bag okay I know Steve Anne
and personally dudes a eases the era
of robert taft limited government
conservatism it's not relevant it's just
not relevant okay well he was saying it
wasn't relevant five minutes ago also so
all the people who already said that
small government wasn't relevant are
still saying small government isn't
relevant so what exactly is their is
their proposal here that we blow up
government spending and we inflate the
currency by the way that's the next step
here we are pouring six to seven
trillion dollars of money into the
economy that's we're gonna have to
inflate the currency at some point to
pay back all the money that we have
borrowed over the next year you are
gonna start to see some actual inflation
there was there was talk about there
wouldn't be inflation in 2007-2008 yes
because it was a financial crisis many
money came out of the actual economy in
the there was there was lack of actual
ability of banks to fund loans at this
point there's a lack of demand pumping
money into the economy just means extra
money in the economy which means that
your savings are worthless prices are
gonna start rising with inflation that
will happen over the next couple of
years your savings are going to be
degraded according to Gerald Seif and
John McCormick writing for The Wall
Street Journal the Great Depression
produced both a bigger social safety net
and a host of new government programs
World War two led to the creation of a
unified Defense Department the Cold War
spawned an interstate highway system in
just the past two decades the
terrorist attacks produced new
consolidated agencies to handle Homeland
Security and National Intelligence the
2008 financial meltdown led to a broad
range of new actions by the Federal
Reserve that are being replicated and
expanded now today both parties and a
vast majority of voters have come
together behind a broad and aggressive
response at both the federal and state
level and have accepted a sea of new red
ink at a time the federal budget deficit
was already heading toward a trillion
dollars annually yes there is a
difference between a vast emergency
caused by government forced shutdowns
and systemic changes to the American
economy that outlasts those shutdowns
and the fact that crisis always breeds
growth in government and that the
retrenchment of government after word
that it goes down to from 10 to 7 it
doesn't mean it goes down from 10 to 0
and that's dangerous in a recent Wall
Street Journal new NBC News poll voters
of both political parties said by a
two-to-one margin they approved of the
expansion of government's role in the
economy to meet the crisis that of
course has to happen to meet the crisis
but the point is what happens after this
is no longer a crisis it's just a bad
situation and this grand notion the
government can save everybody from this
stuff it's been loudly disproved by the
actual past and the the Republicans
thank God are already starting to push
back against this but the fact is there
is a ratchet effect that every time
there is a crisis you start to see
government spending rise and then once
it goes back down to quote unquote
normal it never goes back down to where
it was before
people who are already calling for
bigger government people like Oren cast
he's already calling for bigger
government and he says ok well we need
more bigger government anyway right
you're starting to see people who are
already calling for the government to
outpace everything else calling for more
of that ok now here's the problem it
doesn't work
ok the Great Depression was prolonged by
7 years by the New Deal the New Deal was
a ridiculous government set of policies
that were unconstitutional in the
extreme that not only seized private
property but also wasted a bucketload of
taxpayer dollars drove GDP spending
levels up to catastrophic proportions
and kept unemployment rates 10 to 20
percent in real terms all the way up
till the beginning of World War two the
New Deal was a gigantic failure an
enormous gigantic failure according to
Harold Cole and Leo hanyan is all the
way back in 2009 two professors at UCLA
School of Business they pointed out that
the New Deal did not restore employment
in fact
even less work on average during the New
Deal than before FDR took office total
hours worked per adult including
government employees were 18% below
their 1929 levels between 1930 and 32
there were 23 percent lower on average
during the New Deal private hours worked
were even lower after FDR took office
averaging 27 percent below their 1929
level even comparing hours worked at the
end of the 1930s to those of the
beginning of FDR's presidency doesn't
paint a picture of recovery why wasn't
the depression followed by a vigorous
recovery like every other cycle it
should have been the economic
fundamentals that drive all expansions
were very favorable during the New Deal
productivity grew rapidly after 1933 the
price level was stable real interest
rates were low liquidity was plentiful
so what exactly happened the New Deal
some New Deal policies certainly
benefited the economy by establishing
basic social safety nets say these these
guys but I think that's probably not
even true but others violated basic
economic principles they suppress the
competition they set prices and wages in
many sectors well above their normal
levels by the way this is one of the
great dangers once you make the
government the lender a first resort the
government is gonna start lending to
politically favorable groups and once
that happens that's a lot of money out
the door for no apparent reason it means
regulating it means preventing people
from actually being able to do business
that's the direction Democrats want to
move I've said before there are several
reasons why I'm grateful to trump as
president during this pandemic it's one
of the times have actual been most
grateful that Trump is president not for
some of some of the silly things he says
but for the fact that he is not
attempting to use a crisis to completely
rewrite the bargain of the American
people in the government about the
economy you can see Democrats are
desperate to do this stuff Democrats
would like to see the government expand
Kirsten Gillibrand has an entire piece
of the New York Times today talking
about how we need to subsidize the u.s.
mail and then she's calling for
vote-by-mail Universal vote-by-mail
despite the fact that voter fraud is the
easiest thing in the world with
universal vote by mail and voter vote
gathering is one of the more corrupt
issues in America right now when it
comes to voting the idea that you as a
Democrat you target all the Democratic
homes you stop by their houses and you
pick up their ballots for them and then
you drop those off ballot harvesting
which is what we have here in California
super-duper corrupt because that's not
equal access to the ballot box that's
equal access to the person who's going
to pick up your ballot which is not
equal because it turns out then now you
basically have funded party opera
apparatuses picking up votes from people
so who
that's really where campaign finance
starts to make a difference if you've
got an apparatus that is funded with
hundreds and millions of dollars for the
Democratic Party and hundreds millions
of dollars for the Republican Party and
one dude for the Libertarian Party who
do you think is picking up the votes all
of this is stupidity but this is gonna
be the great battle the great battle is
gonna be between people who thought
America was a pretty damn amazing place
before this and think that America is
still a dams amazing place and once we
come out of this and as we start to
recover in a different world that the
fundamental principles underlying
America still are eternal and good and
true and free economies still work and
lays a fair is still going to be the
best solution fluidity in business
creative destruction is still a thing
and people who believe that this is an
opportunity to completely recast and
remould America the people who always
believed America was a bad place that
required grand governmental intervention
in order to shore up institutions that
they particularly like that's gonna be
the new battle that battle never stopped
it was going on before this it's gonna
go on after this so watch for the under
certain things change certain things do
not the underlying fundamentals of of
that are not going to change the only
thing that's gonna change that this
can't last I mean what is happening
right now cannot last right we're gonna
go back to work the question is gonna be
under what circumstances and more
importantly for the country what the
future of America is gonna look like is
gonna look like massive continuing
governments and intervention in the
economy from both parties because you
can always buy voters or is gonna look
like a principle to return to basic
principles that made us the most
prosperous country in world history and
using a crisis as an opportunity to
break that bargain is a mistake okay
time for some stuff I like and then a
good deal of stuff that I hate so stuff
that I like today so I've been watching
as I've pointed out I have small
children this means that I spend an
awful lot of time viewing children's
movies and kids literature so this movie
got some flack from people mainly for
the CGI of it CGI didn't really bother
me in this movie it was really charming
my kids loved it loved it the new movie
the call of the wild with Harrison Ford
which I will admit my kids are six and
three and so I will not say that they
understood the the end particularly
while I sort of glossed over what
exactly happens at the end of this movie
but the movie is is moving and charming
and the kids love dogs so it is perfect
for them it is it is really good for for
young kids is not particularly scary so
it's
it's definitely worth the watches a
little bit the trailer for call of the
wild how do you feel about an adventure
beyond all maps we should go you and I
where no one's ever been before
see what's out there
[Music]
glad you're enjoying this
I never saw him believe in anything as
much as he believes in you
[Music]
comparison Port Harrison Ford's really
ill invest last me 35 minutes in the
film but the film is is it's fun it's
great my kids really enjoyed it so I
recommend it for kids worth worth the
watch also the music's great john powell
is one of the best living film composers
and he does the score to the scale said
How to Train Your Dragon so you'll hear
some similarities ok other things that I
like today so I will say I love this
over-the-top ridiculous piece by Bill
weirdly CNN chief of climate
corresponding he wrote a piece called to
my son born in the time of coronavirus
and climate change whoo boy and so first
of all let me point out I have a
daughter she was also born in this time
my daughter is now 7 weeks old she was
born March 4th and um I'm not gonna
write her a letter about what a
difficult life she is likely to lead
because guess what I don't think that's
true I think my daughter is likely to
lead a fantastic life with the help of
God but it's not touch time and Ebro
with the help of God she's likely to
lead an incredible life she's likely to
live in still the wealthiest society in
human history she's likely to live a
healthy happy peaceful life because the
modern world is a phenomenal place
filled with amazing technologies and
tremendous abilities and prosperity
she's likely to live in a time of
increasing environmental quality not
decreasing environmental quality because
the fact is that people care about the
environment people going to adjust to
the needs of the environment my daughter
is likely to live a happy fulfilled life
but how would you like to burden your
brand-new born with your life is just
gonna be a bleep hole of pain and rage
that's what bill weir does he wrote a
piece called he wrote a piece about his
Kenya wrote my dearest river and first
of all always great news when your name
yeah I mean you could tell where this is
going I remember is a your name akin
River by all means enjoy but I didn't
name my kid tree that's all I'll say
my dearest river against all odds you
were conceived in a lighthouse about TM
I didn't need to know that didn't need
to know what the with like like like a
lighthouse with like with like Willem
Dafoe and Robert Pattinson or what born
during a pandemic and will taste just
enough of life as we knew it to resent
us when it's gone I'm sorry I'm sorry we
broke your sea in your sky and shortened
the wings of the nightingale I'm sorry
that the Great Barrier Reef is no longer
great and we value Amazon trademark more
than the Amazon and that the waterfront
neighborhood where you
in my arms could be condemned by rising
seeds before you're old enough for a
mortgage seriously really like this is
this is the kids like a day old hell's
wrong with you hey and it feels like
that's the Great Barrier Reef is no
longer great make the Barrier Reef great
again the sense of your downy crown
makes my heart explode the curl in your
Tic Tac Toe fills me with enough love to
power New York City if only if only we
could have cities powered by love Oh
instead the milk in your bottle was
warmed by dirty ancient fuels and as a
result you'll learn to walk on a planet
that has never been this hot for humans
okay so I guess we're not doing the
breastfeeding then we are just now
wrestling with the implications of this
but as your pop the most poignant
evidence was seeing your mother give you
your first kiss through a p100 mask that
smelled faintly of smoke I'm sorry my
boy but we were warned
see for decades scientists told us if we
weren't careful humans would unleash an
invisible enemy out of the jungle and
into our lungs but that was a story if
you wanted to believe so we kept cutting
down jungles and prairies and mangroves
in the last few places where the wild
things are to pave and plow develop and
devour everything in sight okay so now
I'm just gonna point something out okay
is it's kind of important
this coronavirus was started by a bat
you know what's actually great for not
being infected by bats not eating them
and we're interacting with them you know
it's great for not eating in or
interacting with bats pavement it turns
out you know bats are not really fond of
civilization they live a lot more in the
wild I love that his answer like this
pig in this egg notion that nature took
its revenge plague has been part of
human existence and non-human existence
for the entire history of biology but
for Bill Weir it's all about we built an
extra bedroom in Manhattan and now the
bats came for you the hell is wrong with
these people
and this is their chief climate
correspondent I definitely trust him to
be an objective news reporter very
objectivism objective lots of journalism
inc happening over at CNN as you get
older this will be hard to understand
but we were under the spell of Genesis
1:28 I know this is the time where the
environmentalists rip on the Bible it's
all the Bible's fault guys which has
been around for 3,000 years and we
didn't have air pollution for most of
that as you get older this will be hard
to understand but we were under the
spell of Genesis 1:28
to take dominion over every living thing
we had the strange urge to carve
straight lines out of nature's curves
and we're under the spell of uniquely
human force called profit motive the
same thing that gives bill we're a job
at CNN as opposed to being a loser
living in a yurt on the fringes of
civilization by the way Genesis also
says that you have to take care for the
environment you're supposed to actually
take care and guard all the natural
resources that we have when we finally
realized that worried scientists were
right people got scared when searching
for potions and protections they emptied
store shelves even faster than the
jungles and all the invisible enemy
masks were gone just in time for your
birth your mom and I were so scared I
was just about to swallow hard and pay a
faceless soulless internet profiteer
$600 for $0.50 and 95 when I remembered
the mask I used to protect my lungs from
a firey place called California Heather
what California pretty great I live here
also I saw that faceless soulless
Internet profits here like you couldn't
get the n95 anywhere else could you
profit motives very bad except how it
produces the n95 that you wanted to buy
it might have saved your mom from the
virus so I keep it next to my hurricane
waiters malaria pills and the
bulletproof vests with the patch that
reads press he's a hero I hear all if I
have to pack them in case you could buy
more often than you'd like I'm sorry but
we were warned for generations
scientists told us we weren't careful a
different kind of invisible enemy would
come out of our farms factories homes
and cars get into the sky and the sea
and end life as we know it but that was
a story too few wanted to believe
including me today's coronavirus carbon
dioxide and methane molecules don't care
what we believe the laws of physics have
no regard for how we vote or what we
worship so this will be your first life
lesson Little River we are human and
unlike all the other animals we are made
of stories yeah this goes on like a long
time and he talked about how the Bible
is super terrible too terrible bad we
burn gasoline for no good reason
he says you mean like the no good reason
of keeping billions and people live
billions of people alive he says he says
every Christmas and summer vacation I'd
go visit your grandpa bill in the
mountains of Colorado as we hiked
paddled and explored I'd hear very
different stories with heroes like John
Muir or Edward Abbey Rachel Carson
Rachel Carson by the way is responsible
in large part for the
in malarial deaths in Africa because she
got rid of DDT which was one of the keys
to keeping mosquito population down he
says even as plenty of many he talked
about had the evils of Hiroshima mean
that this whole thing is just insane
it's insane
he's a small child and he's talking
about how evil America is and like I
feel bad for this kid this kid is gonna
become an alright fanatic just have just
a piss off dad that's gonna happen with
this kid this kid is gonna be like on
the internet digging into the evils of
Reddit and 4chan within 5 minutes of
being born kids already on the internet
right now in the year before you were
born says bill weir I took a road trip
across America the science is my map I
set out from the Florida Keys to Alaska
from the heartland to burnt paradise all
to imagine how uh natural disasters will
change our future I met fire at farmers
firefighters fishermen politicians
protesters paleoclimatologists I came
home completely rattled because the
American Way of life I grew up with is
already gone the Goldilocks climate that
allowed humanity to thrives in the past
and nobody seems to know it yet if we do
nothing it will mean the end of
predictable growing seasons flight
schedules supply chains resource Wars
tens of millions of climate refugees
changing everything we know about
borders neighbors and strangers if we
give up on our most primal job we have
as humans haven't we already lost go
right ahead and then at the very end
he's like you're your grandpa would
track you up to a glorious twisted
biological fate because we thought we
were too old to become new parents we
were the last thing we imagined on a
vacation to Croatia where your
great-grandpa Frank was born until we
found and we found a dubrovnik
lighthouse on Airbnb until you know what
it's like to fall in love the story will
make you blush and squirm but I can
think of no better omen for the kind of
boy we hope to raise than the fact that
we made sweet sweet love at the table in
Croatia the lighthouse keepers vigilant
and dependable with the reverence for
nature's power commitment to saving
lives this is your destiny my beautiful
river the great thing about stories is
they are always under a vision now go
write a happy ending oh yeah I feel
terrible for this kid what Wow okay time
for a quick thing that I hate I really
enjoyed that
temporal quick thing I hate
so we're still talking about this whole
injecting Clorox routine so as I pointed
out last week president Trump has a
habit his habit is he says lots of stuff
and this is something I have not just
pointed out now I point them pointing
this forum for five years at this point
president Trump says a lot of stuff
that's why we used to have a feature on
the program called good Trump bad Trump
which we may have to bring back at some
point had a theme song in everything
well good Trump is that his activities
during the pandemic like actual things
the feds have done are good the bad
Trump is that the stuff that Trump says
at his press conference is very often
odd and very often this is because
apparently according to reports he
actually doesn't meet with his pandemic
task force it's not like he gets bad
gets together behind closed doors and
just spends time with them basically the
first time he hears from them he gets a
bunch of note cards that he's going to
read it as press conferences and then
after the press conferences then he and
then at the press conferences like the
first time he seen Burks in today and so
will say the birth stuff that just pops
into his head okay what if we could
bring sunlight inside the human body
he'll do that kind of stuff okay is that
the end of the world no it's not the end
of the world he said a dumb thing he
said it last week okay I'm not gonna
pretend it wasn't them it was a dumb
thing is it a dangerous thing are people
gonna start going and injecting Clorox
if you do frankly Darwin can have you
because if you are injecting Clorox
because the president was like maybe we
could bring disinfectant inside the
human body then you're and then you're
you're stupid you're stupid okay like I
have no cure for the stupid does that
mean that Trump is actively telling
people that they should go out to Costco
and buy some bleach and down it of
course not but because we have a
fundamentally unserious media and a
fundamentally unserious Democratic Party
they take everything Trump says at face
value and instead of just dismissing
this stuff as dumb which it is instead
of just dismissing it we get a full news
cycle about how people are going to
inject themselves with Drano or some
such nonsense so Nancy Pelosi over the
weekend decided to make the most of this
situation and she started talking about
injecting yourself with Clorox like why
this is still a conversation is beyond
me except it's not I mean it's obviously
politically motivated we just have to
have a path to the future if we're going
if and when we can open up testing
testing testing
tracing tracing tracing isolation well
the one we're ready we'll go out there
but we all there's planning we spend a
lot of time what the president said went
right and disinfected in the body you
know what they call that they call that
embalming that's the medical term okay
first of all Nancy Pelosi knows more
than most about what embalming looks
like but beyond that the fact that Nancy
Pelosi is still making an issue out of
this also by the way that's not a plan
when you say testing testing testing
tracing fixing picking what the hell
does that mean thanks for saying words
Nancy Pelosi now how much testing how
much tracing how do you propose to do
this what do you think that plan looks
like it's thanking bombing it says the
lady who shoves more Botox in a forehead
than has been created in most of human
life Mike my god so the media started
playing this up over the weekend they
suggested that calls to poison control
were spiking that people were going out
and downing Drano and bleach and they're
taking the Lysol and just injecting it
directly into the rains mother well I
will admit that yesterday I was giving
my son a bath and he said what happens
if soap goes in your mouth I said now
you're you're immune to coronavirus so
stupid okay were calls going up no they
weren't going up according to reason
calm on Thursday the president suggested
that perhaps an injection of an
injection of disinfecting could help
cure people of kovin 19 critics of
Donald Trump went to town rightfully so
supporters scramble to settle on a
defense both he didn't really say that
and he did it but it was sarcasm had
been in play like Trump suggested it was
sarcasm it was not sarcasm Trump is not
one for wordplay like that no no okay
but by Saturday morning social media was
abuzz with articles about people calling
poison control centers each crafted to
illustrate how Americans had apparently
taken from some ramblings to heart and
consumed household disinfectants like
Lysol and bleach the problem was the
articles had actually say that there's
one article making the rounds from the
New York Daily News and it was headlined
a spike in New Yorkers ingesting
household cleaners following Trump's
controversial coronavirus comments but
the article doesn't say that it says 30
people called the city's poison control
hotline over fears they had ingested
bleach or other household cleaners
fearing you ingested something doesn't
jibe with having intentionally consumed
the substance you idiots right if I'd
down bleach I don't then call CDC right
if I do it on purpose
I'm not like CDC was that a good idea or
a bad idea
I'm like yeah I don't bleed true but as
reason points out they try to circumvent
this inconvenient fact that the New York
Daily News by noting that over the same
time period in 2019 the poison control
center only handled thirteen similar
cases this time nine calls were about
Lysol and ten about bleach laster's
calls contain no kit no cases reported
about Lysol only two were regards to
bleach okay but um maybe the reason why
people are worried about this is because
lots of people are exposed to household
disinfectants they were not exposed to
this time last year because they weren't
um in lockdown cleaning every available
surface as reason points out this is
just it's just nonsense it's just
silliness but they've decided to make
this an issue in the media because it's
fun because more fun than actually
covering the hard-nosed business of
politics and and policymaking dr.
deborah birx was asked about this over
the weekend and she says frankly it
still bothers me that people are talking
about this is a complete waste of time
it bothers me that this is still in the
news cycle because I think we're missing
the bigger pieces of what we need to be
doing as an American people to pretend
you to protect one another and we should
be having that dialogue about
asymptomatic Swee should be having that
dialogue about this unique clotting that
we're seeing and you know we're the
first country that really had young
people to this degree Italy in Europe is
about eight years older than us as a
median age so this is the first
experience of this virus in an open
society where we really can understand
what's happening to every different age
groups these are the things that we
should be talking about and focusing on
well yes but apparently this is very bad
Emily Nussbaum who's an idiot columnist
for The New Yorker she tweeted out
doctor purse is going to dr. Burks is
going to leave a horrible legacy it's
one thing to be a cynical paid fixer
it's worse in my eyes to be the expert
who props up the Mad King I get that
it's an emergency
I understand the theoretical strategy
she may be may think she's pursuing but
it's a moral horror
so her pointing out that you spending
all of your time fulminating over Trump
saying a dumb thing is a waste of time
that's immoral but its moral horror for
her to say that it probably would be
better if she quit and left from
completely free of good scientific
advisers and let the American people
that basically fend for themselves so
you could feel good about yourself Emily
Nussbaum just idiotic
the media by the way again having a
field day because this is all they care
about Jim Acosta and ladies find you
who loves you like Jim Acosta loves Jim
Acosta he says there's not enough
disinfectant to wipe away the White
House's lies which does pre-write these
things then think they sound good does
he exceed them dramatically in the
mirror to Jim Acosta
it's like Jim Acosta that's a great line
I know Jim Acosta thanks so much here's
Jim Acosta I think we found out today
that the president's words have meaning
but they're also at times hazardous to
your health and I think that was part of
what we learned today and go into you're
pointing us and there just isn't enough
disinfecting at the White House to wash
away what the president did and the lies
that were told to try to cover it up I
will tell you Anderson one of the
reasons why he cut short that briefing
earlier this evening my sources tell me
is because the president was upset about
the flack he was taking over his
comments
Wow yeah did he write that one like how
long in advance how long until Jim
Acosta makes a lysol joke right you
can't disinfect with Lysol he needs a
guy named Saul on the other end so you
can say you can't disinfected lies Saul
maybe we need some more puns by the way
speaking of wordplay the president
engaged in some very witty word play
over the weekend according to the
president was an actual wordplay anyway
Trump is angry the news conferences he
doesn't want to do them anymore which
but fine like seriously I'm cool with
that
the president's weeded out what is the
purpose of having White House news
conferences when the lamestream media
asked nothing but hostile questions and
then refuses to report the facts or
truth accurately they get record ratings
the American people get nothing but fake
news not worth the time and effort agree
100% agree
remember a week ago the Wall Street
Journal editorial board said he's
probably not to the news conferences he
was like I always love doing them my
ratings are unbelievable
one week later he's like not doing him
any more poop on you okay good
fine okay better outcome better outcome
he follow it on that by just ripping
everybody so the president obvious he's
like I'm not frustrated I'm gonna crap
all over everything like a pigeon over a
car park I'm just gonna go for it so the
president so the president tweeted out
first a bunch of stuff about Nobel
Prizes he called them Nobel Prizes so he
deleted all these tweets his first
tweets he tweeted out and then deleted
them
hours later he said he said when will
all of the reporters who have received
Nobel Prizes for their work on Russia
Russia Russia only to have been
proven totally wrong and in fact it was
the other side who committed the crimes
be turning back their cherished nobles
so that they can be given to the real
reporters and journalists who got it
right he said he could give the Nobel
Committee a very comprehensive list of
those he deemed real reporters and then
he said lawsuits should be brought
against all including fake news
organizations to rectify this terrible
injustice when will the Nobel Committee
act better be fast so there are a few
problems here one there is no Nobel
Prize for journalism it's called the
Pulitzer two Nobel is spelled nobe L not
n OB le and this all prompted the
president eventually to delete all of
these sweets and then put up another
tweet in which he explained he was just
engaged in a bit of Oscar Wilde witty
word play because that's what the
president is known for the the witty
word play he tweeted out does anybody
get the meaning of what a so-called Noba
not Nobel Prize is especially as it
pertains to reporters and journalists
Nova is defined as quote having or
showing a fine personal qualities or
high moral principles and ideas the
sarcasm ever work we were all living in
a world Donald Trump's irony and
illusions in alliteration onomatopoeia
I'm glad that we've had this literary
lesson from the president he also
dripped into Fox News by the way as well
as The Wall Street Journal none of this
is what we need at this point so I'm
glad that the president has canceled the
press conferences they are a waste of
time they are posturing by the media we
don't need them and the president also
should calm his ass down like seriously
when it comes to this kind of stuff like
fulminating it's just it's
counterproductive if you want to see
Trump reelected you know what is a bad
idea this a bad idea would be this just
spending all day on Twitter fulminating
about Fox News in the Wall Street
Journal who do you think is out there
defending you like you're gonna find
like oann ain't gonna cut it okay I like
a lot of the people who go in and then
I'm just telling you oh and ain't gonna
be able to lift the singular burden of
being able to defend defensible and good
policies from the Trump administration
alienating Fox News in the Wall Street
Journal is just brilliant political
tactics it just like genius genius stuff
you know we need right now what we've
needed all along the policy of the Trump
administration without the president
saying this kind of stuff same thing
we've needed forever because the fact is
Joe Biden is vulnerable he continues to
be a garbage candidate the media by the
way demonstrate what he says about the
rest of
is mainly true when he says the media
are terrible at their jobs 100 century
when he rips them about the Russian
collusion stuff 100% true and by the way
when he rips them for being biased also
100% sure you know what happened over
the weekend
CNN there's a tape of there's there's an
accuser of Joe Biden named Tara Reed she
accuses Joe Biden back in 1993 of having
sexually assaulted her the media refused
to cover its he hadn't reported it for
the first time over the weekend that's
only because the Center for Media
Research Media Research Center Brent
pizzelles organization uncovered a tape
of Tara Reid's mother in 1993 calling in
to Larry King and talking about this
thing here was that tape I'm wondering
what a staffer would to do besides go to
the press in Washington
my daughter has just left there after
working for a prominent senator and
could not get through with her problems
at all
and the only thing she could have done
was go to the press and she chose not to
do it out of respect for him or she had
a story to tell but out of respect for
the person she worked for she didn't
tell it okay so Sarah Reed's mom right
so we now have more contemporaneous
evidence of action by Joe Biden then we
have contemporaneous evidence of
anything with regard to Christine Blasi
Ford and and Brett Kavanaugh the media
didn't wrote that not a single one of
Joe Biden's potential VP candidates all
women we're asked about this on the
sunday shows so when Trump rips into the
media he's a hundred percent correct a
hundred percent correct that is all
deserved like a little bit of
circumspect leadership here would be a
good thing we are fundamentally
unserious but we have fundamentally
unserious politicians on all sides we
have fundamentally unserious people in
the media and that lack of seriousness
at a time when we all need to be kind of
serious this is why again I trust the
American people far more than the media
far more than the politicians the
American people can take care of
themselves better than the media and
better than the politicians because the
American people are more serious about
their own lives than they are about the
politician so before you had more power
to media and politicians recognize that
the people leading our country are
morons and that's a court that's all of
them everyone okay virtually everyone
cannot connect ignite that they don't
know as much about you as much as you do
about how to lead your own life and
aside from taking basic protective
measures to protect the vulnerable and
aside from making sure that the
resources that should have been
available originally are now available
to hospitals because this is all
government exists
do they need to get out of your way and
they need to let you get back to
business and then that what need to let
you lead your life because you're gonna
be more responsible than the politicians
who spend all of their time doing the
wrong things and focused on idiocy z'
for political gain and the members of
the media who are busily focused in on
self aggrandizement at the cost of
actual human lives in one case and the
cost of actual human quality of life on
the other alrighty we'll have two
additional hours of content a little bit
later today also we will be back here
tomorrow so we'll see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew clave and host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Klavan show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]